[Music]
okay hello everyone and
welcome to insane in the end game
um
and uh here where we're going to be
looking at end games
uh so here we're going to see a game
from
the 1957
world championship
match between uh mikhail botvinnik and
vasily smithslav
very interesting end game the game up to
this point was not interesting so we're
not going to see it besides the fact
that it
that it doesn't fit in with our topic
but
also it wasn't very interesting but now
it starts to get quite interesting but
finnick as white got nothing out of the
opening it was kind of struggling to
make a draw
uh decided he should try to make a draw
which was a rational decision and reach
this end game where
it would appear it's not too far away
but
black has some advantage
here
um
[Music]
first of all
he has more space on the queen side this
is one thing the other thing
is that the white pawns on the king side
are
a little bit weak
this pawn on e3 and also he might have a
problem with the pawn on g3
and potentially the bishop well it's a
relatively close position but as we'll
see there's a potential energy with this
bishop
but the main thing is that white's queen
side pawns can be attacked and the black
pawns
are giving black a little bit extra
space there so black is continuing to
play for a win
but finnick didn't have any illusion
probably that it was going to be a
simple draw at this point
smithslav began with knight c4
attacking both pawns b2 and e3
and white had to respond with knight to
d1
and here i
smithlove made it a move which i think
was a little bit of a strange decision
it looks very natural to try to fix
white's pawns on the king side rather
than allowing the move g4
to fix the pawns with the move h5
obviously not f5 because this will
weaken the squares but h5
this move uh
fixes the weakness on g4 and also fixes
this pawn here but smith'll have decided
not to play this move which i think is a
little bit surprising
and a little questionable it to me i
think
the move king f7 which he played was not
was not as good as h5
so he he actually played king of seven
though
and
now but vinik
surprisingly also chose not to play g4
but i think the g4
is definitely either now or on the next
move definitely best g4 and while it's
true that's
for instance after h5 g5
white will be left with this pawn which
is potentially vulnerable with a knight
sometime coming to f5
on the other hand
it when the pawn is left on g3 it's also
weak there
there's also a weak pawn
from here the pawn can only be attacked
from f5 and not not also e4
but the main thing is that the king side
remains closed and it's i don't think
black can win this position
but
but vinik played first b3
the knight and after knight to d6
now again he could have played g4 but he
decided to play king g2
and this time smith changed his mind and
decided it was time to play h5
so i think at this point he was back on
the right track
and now budvinic
strangely enough although he could have
played g4 on the previous two moves
decided
he should
um he should uh
play g4 now once black has played h5
probably because he realized that there
were some problems for instance
well he played king h3 if he played
knight e1 this is the this is the other
way to try to get counter play
with a knight coming to d3 and then to
c5
but for instance after 91 black could
starts with king e7
knight 394
aiming to bring the knight into c3
and then if white plays knight f2 black
can play knight c3 and white has to
blockade like this and then black could
break with e5 so he realized that
basically
um
black could make a lot of counter a lot
of progress and then for instance if
white takes then
black can play this way and then take on
e5 followed by bishop to b2 and upon
queens
or if if
if white plays 91 to blockade the pawn
on c2 then black can start bringing the
king like this
white has to play king f3 and then e4
and
first this move and then king g4 and
white is stuck in totally passive
position and
for instance b4 takes takes and then
black if white doesn't play this move
he's with it left without a move
this kind of position this is zug swung
because the pawn is under attack
um
if b4 then
here black can come back with the king
and bring the king around and eventually
king comes up takes the pawn and black
is winning here so
just showing this line pretty quickly
because i don't have time to go into
every detail about this but
for for reasons like this but vinik
decided that it was better not to try to
defend passively and he played king h3
um so now
knight e4 so black's idea is eventually
to bring the knight into c3
force the exchange and white will have
to deal with this past pawn and black
will try to break through elsewhere on
the board
okay so
g4 hg4 king g4
f5 king h3 bishop of six
and
here
um
white needs to bring the knight over to
to the queen side to try to defend
um if white tried for instance knight g5
can anyone tell me what black might play
here
anyone online or one of you
want to see how black can carry out his
plan
same thing after 95.
bishop takes yeah very good jay drew
bishop takes ok pawn takes and then what
then knight to c3 very good jeju knight
c3
okay so this is the idea white needs
this knight
the other night okay because black is
constantly threatening knight of knights
c3
so he went 91 because the knight won't
be needed to blockade on c2 or maybe to
go to d3 in some cases so he went here
um
now how is black going to make any
progress
this is this is a key position
uh
yeah
i've gone through it a little bit
quickly up to this point but right now
we'll start to see some
try to understand how black's going to
make powers i think white would find the
g4 early on had a
pretty relatively simple draw and not
simple completely but he
but here let's try to figure out this
position what is black going to do
any ideas from people online or in
person you do you have any ideas people
here
no
bishop d8 okay what's the idea of bishop
d8 nicholas
knight's going to come to c3
uh-huh
okay so jay drew came up with idea
um
yeah
jay drew came up with the idea okay
we're going to play knight c3 at some
point and clearly the white knight will
be tied to c2
we'll go to c2
the bishop is not going to be able to go
to a3 though
and white's going to sit and wait with
the king
in that position
okay so as we're but we're learning more
about the position we as we look at the
different ideas the players can play
um the different ideas that uh you know
the plans and the different uh kinds of
ideas that can be carried out
we start to figure out more about what's
going on
so
what else can black do
clearly can't just win on win on the
queen's side right
because white will have after knight c3
white will take and oops white will take
and have a blockade with the knight on
c2
king h very good jeju king h5 and go
after the h pawn and that's exactly what
smithslav played he played king g7
with a very natural plan using the
principle of two weaknesses
the king will go to h5 whereas while the
knight will go to c3 forcing white to
exchange it
the c pawn is one weakness from white's
point of view
because he has to watch it always to
prevent it from queening and the h pawn
is the other weakness
it looks simple enough but this move
king g7 is a serious mistake which could
have given botvinnik an easy draw
um or well after after the next move at
least
um the idea but because he omitted a
crucial detail
so let's think about this king g7 okay
white played knight to d3
and here black played knight c3
that's his idea
knight c3
white had to take pawn takes and what do
you think about phoenix should play here
now that's uh no drew you found the
right idea the right plan but
um
he missed a prophylactic idea here white
to play in this position
if if
91 knight c2 that's exactly what black
wants
uh-huh
okay jj yeah 91 to c2 well in that case
knight d3 wouldn't have made much sense
would it
in fact white did play 91 so at this
point he did find the move the master
played but it was a mistake
so i'm surprised about vinick maybe
there's some time pressure i'm surprised
he
he didn't play
a different move here which would give
him a draw
91
after 91 the black king starts coming to
h6 and it's exactly
well
exactly as
as as
as was intended
uh b3 is pawn's already on b3 maybe you
mean b4
nagarai
yes b4 very good
b4 is the move he needed to play
and now if black play if black takes it
this position is an easy draw for white
now
because this a pawn will be a diversion
for black
which um
well
this this a pawn will be a diversion for
black for instance
uh
if black continues with his plan king h6
let's say
um
then white can play a4
and black has to stop the pawn from
advancing further
bishop d8
and now
white can just sit here with
for instance knight
c2 how's black going to make any
progress
if he moves his king up okay white goes
back
oh thank you
if he takes the pawn then
this pawn starts getting too far ahead
well i think that this
yeah
yeah
and then after bishop d8
a6
and black has to play like this move and
now the white king can start heading to
the queen side
and there's no way that black can win
this position he's
he has to deal as soon as white takes
the c pawn white already threatens
knight c6 so
meanwhile if we go back here okay after
after b4
black could play
yeah nicholas not knight c6 in that
position because the c pawn would queen
but
first the king comes over threatening
knight c6
black could try a4 but after this white
would play b5 and once again this pawn
is a threat
and after black goes bishop here then
the white king just starts coming over
again white will give up the h pawn
king comes up let's say white gives up
the h pawn
but now he's in the square of black c
pawn
and
suddenly what does white play here
counter play right what does white do
here
anyone
knight e5 uh
maybe but
95 okay black goes
uh goes king h5 perhaps
maybe 95 as well
knight c5 i think is even stronger
because this pawn just
just
falls and of course the white king
easily deals with black pawn black is in
trouble here
so this would be over pressing
so
b4 i can't see any chance for black to
win this position as we saw b a b this a
pawn is a diversion if white plays a if
black plays a4 then b5 it's diversion
so going back
when black played
91 king g7
black missed
uh missed a subtle move which would have
been the way to keep the pressure on
white and keep the advantage
he wants to play knight c3 but it has to
be prepared first with so prophylactic
thinking
avoiding what white is intending can
anyone find the right move
for black
anyone
a4 well a4 white just takes it right
that would that would be good for white
we want to play knight c3
but the main thing is to prevent then
white from following up with b4
uh sam bishop b7
do you mean something else maybe with
the bishop
bishop e7 right very good
so
yes bishop e7 was the move this was a
key move for black to play this move
and now
the point is that um
well if he had played this for instance
if white continues knight d3 then knight
c3
takes takes and white doesn't get b4 in
so he just had to prepare it and then
for instance 91
yeah
for instance 91 and then black continues
as in the game so we'll get to that kind
of position
but so instead black began with this 923
and he played knight c3
and white took it and black took back
and instead of b4 white went 91
allowing the black to well avoiding the
missing the possibility of b4 which
would have held the game for him
so now smithslav continued with king h6
knight c2 and what do you think he
played here this time he played the
right move
what do you think he played here
okay well if king h5 white could have
gone before then if he went here
before
and
um
suddenly white gets those same chances
again as before
so very good nicholas this time bishop
e7 so now with it right in front of him
easily found now it seems like well
it seems so obvious when you look at it
yeah of course before knight c3 you have
to play be avoid the b4 move with the
pres
the preparation bishop b7 but it's not
as obvious as it might seem
especially when you're sitting at the
board and there's many other things to
think of think of
bishop e7
here white played king g3
okay he could try to play a3 and b4 by
the way you might be wondering about
this but this makes a big difference
with the pawn on a3 makes a huge
difference because the pawn's on dark
square so for instance if a3
king h5 b4
black takes
and now if knight takes
then black takes to the knight right
so that's not possible it's black
queen's the pawn so pawn takes
now black can take this after b5 bishop
d8 and in this case
this pawn is vulnerable and black can
start bringing his king back
to capture that pawn
in this case so
um
play something start with uh
for instance king g3 g5 takes takes king
f3 bishop a5 so this pawn is always
going to be protected
and if white goes king e2 then here
black could actually start invading over
here and the bishop is both stopping the
pawn and stopping a push
and when if white tries doing this kind
of thing then
um
yeah b6 king takes c3
but then black gets king
king e2
and white is squeezed out fatally here
it's only an extra pawn it's true but
white can't guard this forever
and white runs out of moves actually so
we're going to see some positions
similar to that
so
the a3 move would have not really worked
here so white played king g3
and he just gave up his h-pawn
but he still has his hopes now the game
changes a little bit white is now on the
verge of defeat but he has good chances
to hold a blockade in this kind of
position the knight is on the because of
the light squares he has a slight square
blockade
okay
so
after king takes h4
yeah if white goes a4 this would be
giving up some opportunities so we don't
need to play a4 at this point
he instead just moves his knight back
and forth
knight's e2 the knight
e1 black takes takes
and the knight's just going to revolve
back and forth and black's going to
struggle to make progress
because if the black king goes around
the queen side somehow
then the white king can come and take
black c pawn
if bishop b4 white will have a3 to drive
it away
now white can't just go take the c pawn
if the black king is on the king's side
because as we saw before
black will invade with his king to f3
and white will be squeezed out he'll run
out of space
so but that means black can't move his
king away he has to invade with his king
on the king's side
so let's let's try to find a way so so
he started with this move knight e1 king
h4 knight c2
king here and can anyone after knight
a1 can anyone find a way for black to
make progress on the king's side and and
get his king into the game in into
white's position
anyone online or in person
basically he wants to try to get his
king around somehow or to try to push
the white king back to stop this
king edge very good nicholas king h2
threatening to come oops threatening to
come this way
and after king f2 bishop g3
very good and now after king f3 though
what here
bishop h4 good job bishop h4
moving the bishop out of
uh it's on pre-position and
uh planning to bring the king this way
without allowing king f2
so now white waited and then king g1 and
white holds the line now one rank or one
file further back
king e2 he has to stop king f1 because
if he doesn't
black just gets gets here and white's
not going to be able to keep the knight
on c2 obviously he'll run out of moves
and then the king will continue and
obviously win
so after king ji won black white had to
play king e2
and now black went king g2 so he's moved
in one
one file over
okay but white is still holding this
light square blockade
now white went knight a1
okay try continuing to
just move back and forth
and how is black going to make progress
from from this position
this is this is where it gets pretty
difficult
can anyone try to think of an idea to
make progress
it almost looks like white just has a
barricade a total barricade here
bishop g5 okay
bishop g5
knight c2
and then what
you can go f4
but white takes it right
and continues waiting let's say now this
one okay
g5
correct i'm just we need to find a plan
black can do a lot of different things
bla bish i can't say bishop g5 is
correct or not it's not um the move he
played but he he made a few tempo moves
but the it's not a position where like
we have black has to find one move we
just he needs to find a plan
this is what we're
this is the uh
you know because this knight is just
going back and forth so it's more of a
kind of schematic thinking which is kind
of what this lecture is about
black has to
think in a way that's well
what am i going to do and he has all the
time in the world here really
i mean you can't repeat the position
three times but
uh you know
so
the only way black could make progress
is whereas extra pawn is over here
caleb taylor says bishop f6 okay yeah
people are saying a lot of moves here
bishop f6 to push the e pawn
very good
okay so that's his idea bishop f6
not really to push the e pawn though
maybe in some cases but also to push the
most of all to push the f pawn so what
he what he actually did was
he did some tempo moves he started with
um
bishop e7 knight c2
he went king g3 okay maneuvered a little
bit and then bishop f6
and
now
white found him in a situ himself in a
situation that he's running out of moves
if
he goes uh i mean if he if he goes
knight a1 if he continues doing this
then black would play what do you think
what do you think if white just
continues waiting 91 or knight e1 either
way this one
f4 yeah threatening f3 so white has to
take it
and then
and then how is what's that
bishop takes yeah king takes king d3 i
think would hold freud but bishop takes
that's why black started with king g3
this pawn is now under attack and looks
like white's losing here
because if king up black can move the
bishop away
and this pawn is protected that pawn is
hanging
white could guard it but eventually that
pawn will fall right black could also
play bishop h6 so
or d3 so
white can't do that so he couldn't move
his knight away he needs to keep his
knight on c2 to protect d4
but if he moves his king
he gives up too much space black would
play now king f3 and white starts really
running away he can take this pawn now
but then black plays king e2 and we get
to this position
where
white is just
well the knight looks really bad even
though it's a relatively close position
the problem is the knight
can't lose a move you can't just sit
here
and white's running out of space so the
knight has to guard e3 or white's lost
and he just runs out of space he could
move his a pawn but black just continues
waiting then
for instance i mean
yeah also black has bishop g5 and then
taking this pawn this way so he just
runs out of space so
uh so white played a3 here so now he
needs to try to well he needs to wait a
move and try to make count threaten
counter play at some point
but this changes the situation now the
pawn is on a3
so now there's a new weakness on the
queen side
so black played bishop e7
keeping the knight tied to a3 white
can't just give up the pawn
so here was an interesting moment
um
white played b4 which lost pretty
cleanly
after b4
what do you think black should play
anyone
f4 but after f4 white takes it right
and if if we get this position f4 takes
king takes and white king goes well of
course white also threatens this but and
the white king goes to d3 let's suppose
black exchanges
plays f4 white exchanges king d3 that's
just drawn
so at best actually for black
so
after b4
ryan says a4 very good at this point if
black had exchanged in this position
then i think white would hold the draw
because it would get b5 and king d3 and
so on
but after a4
now
white is left cramped on the queen side
so in this position white had to play
the other move a4 and at first i thought
when i
looked at this game a long time ago that
there was no way for
um for black to make progress
but now i see that there there is a way
and it's it's a really surprising way
how could black so the idea was that
basically uh
if black tries to use these plans with
f4
um bishop bishop back to f6 and f4 to
try to play as as before to try to force
white to take and then take d4 once the
white knight moves away here white's
white will have whenever the bishop
leaves this diagonal we'll have b4
so black has to very carefully
keep that keep b4 under control whenever
the white knight is on c2 while still
trying to make progress
tom says e5 but if e5 white will just
take on e5 but perhaps e5 can be
prepared right
um
so nicholas says bishop d6 okay bishop
d6
again as before white can't play
king here because he's giving up too
much space in that case black would for
instance king d3 king f3
king takes king e2
and
white has no moves here
runs out of moves especially look at the
knight it has no moves for instance we
go here king d2 and he's really just
just lost lost because he lacks space
so after bishop d6 white has to move the
knights somewhere
if 91
i think here then king f2 knight c2
i think black has to make some kind of
some more maneuvers to reach this
position of white to move
oh actually sorry if 91
yeah
um
oh king sorry after king d3 i'm sorry i
meant in this position of course after
king d3
uh king f3 knight e1
black can just come this way
and then just just uh
make any waiting move for the bishop
like this
once white's already but if white plays
in this position he has to play knight
a1 if knight e1
then
then we'll come to uh yeah knight e1
black can play carry out his plan so now
e5 right once the knight has moved away
plays e5 d takes c5 bishop takes c5 so
knight goes back to c2
um which okay can reach this position
after knight a1 but now how does the the
main point is how does black make
progress here
anyone
d4 exactly
i think black can just
play
d4 right away
and after takes then bishop d6
and reach this position
and as it turns out white can't
handle both past pawns for instance
after bishop d6
king if white
i mean if white tries king d3 f4
king takes c3 f3
knight e3
f2
let's say king d3
and here
black can go bishop f4
knight has to go to f1 and then
black plays
king g2
king e2
and king ju1
and white is left and white is now in
suk's wong
so the idea after f3 to take i here um i
think black would just play knight king
f2
yeah
and knight c2 and then king g2
oh and then there's a check again well
we can play f3 here so
this is
more or less the same thing white won't
be able to stop that pawn
yeah so this this is very different and
then there's of course with the knight
on e1 rather than if it had gone to a1
white has knight d3 in this position so
that's another attempt
but then after bishop d6 it's pretty
much the same thing the main idea is to
go d4
takes
and then
um
and then f4 and
white still can't stop both of these
pawns
so
there's still for instance knight f3
there's always c2
so this is yeah this was not so obvious
that bishop d6 with the idea of e5 and
then d4
sacrificing upon and then bishop d6 it's
it's quite difficult i think there was
some other funny
uh
funny variation now i can't really
remember
what it was but
yeah so at first i and i think this is
what the annotations were at the time
there was a lot of analysis of this and
they didn't didn't find this plan at the
time bishop d6 e5 and then f d4 and then
and then back to d6 and f4 it's quite
hard
okay white played b4 but and here it was
important that black play a4
because otherwise
well he needs to keep this uh keep these
eight pawns
um so here uh
basically
um white's idea is that uh
he's going or black's idea is that well
yeah let's let's ask how black's going
to make progress in this position now
white's still going to just he played 91
he's just going to keep moving his
knight back and forth
how how can black do anything here
the same plan might not
really work
i don't it might actually but
let's see bishop d6 knight c2 e5
might be possible but some in some cases
white's b-pawn can be a diversion so the
in this with this pawn structure on the
queen side in some of those positions
white starts pushing the b pawn and
creates a problem for black
but black had a clearer way to go here
anyone
we've already seen the idea
uh earlier
these pawns have to be attacked
and we can undermine the d-pawn with f4
and for this the bishop has to be
attacking d4 right and
the knight has to be not on c2
so black arranged for that to happen he
went bishop g5 knight c2 bishop of six
and white's and zug's phone
because if the knight moves away
for instance knight e1 again
then what is black play here
f4 right and we already saw this kind of
position earlier okay the queen side
pawn structure is a little bit different
but we already saw this if white takes
then bishop takes
and that pawn will be falling eventually
meanwhile
if white plays b5
the bishop comes here and then it can
come to b6 and from b6
the same zoox fong will be reached
because
bishop will also be attacking d4 and
when the knight moves away f4 the same
the same situation
so for that reason white had to give up
a little bit more space king d3
but this is basically fatal allowing
black to move in with the king king f2
um
and here white uh
tried knight a1 if king takes c3
what would black play
of course if the king gets back to d3
white is fine
anyone
king e2 very good
king e2
taking up a decisive amount of space now
white is still quite as equal material
again
but the knight has absolutely no moves
it's it's just
knight a1 knight back to c2
and this pawn is going nowhere because
black always can stop it and it doesn't
help white white will run out of moves
especially with the bishop then coming
here so for instance here you have b5
bishop d8
king b2 king d2
and
now white just runs out of moves in this
this position for instance
king c4 and black can come back and take
the b pawn
and this and still the knight
just can't get out it will never go to
e2 because always the king and pawn
endings will be winning for black
it will never go to b4
so black takes the pawn comes back to c4
and then invades on d3 or b3
if white doesn't play b5 here if he
plays knight c2
then
black can also play e5 for instance here
and white can't take it because the
knight is lost
and then comes f4 next move
so y just loses because of lack of space
so he tried to hold his last defensive
line with knight a1 knight a1 to c2 back
and forth okay
as before
what can black do now to
finally
run white out of moves
where does the bishop need to go now
because the black king is well placed
i suppose you could try coming along the
back rank with king e1
uh maybe but
there is something else that
was
simpler also i'm not if king one maybe
maybe knight c2 followed by king c
yeah ryan very good bishop g5 except
we want bishop to be on g5
after white has moved knight to c2 and
then white will be in zouk swan so black
lost to move bishop d8 knight c2
bishop g5 another two song
pawn is under attack the knight can't
move because black will just take the
pawn if the king takes on c3
um then black can take on e3 or more
yeah we'll take on
actually black will play king e2 there
taking up the space
um not trading the pieces because then
white white queen's in time i guess but
king e2 and we'll have the same position
as before
so white played b5
okay black can't take on e3
but now black comes back and another
six song will be reached
this time night before for instance or
if night before is what happened
if king c3 king e2 is what we had before
so knight before bishop b6
knight back to c2 bishop a5
now white is again out of moves
so he had to go
well if he goes knight
if he goes knight a1
then
the black king can come across this way
and just come around
this way
so white played knight before but now
again the king came across king he won
and actually white resigned here
because if white ever takes this pawn
then king e2 and black wins
because this pawn will be captured in
the f pawn will queen
and if not the king just comes across
for instance
um knight a2
black can play c2
white can't take it
and then after um
well i mean
white has no moves but if he takes it
then king e2 and black wins because he
takes the pawn and the f pawn queens
okay so there's no moves for white then
um
knight c1 then have king d1
so for that reason white resigned so i
know this was a pretty complicated end
game and well it's
uh yeah very very complicated end game
very difficult to orientate or
orient orient oneself in this uh this
kind of position
um
but it shows a lot of schematic thinking
and i'm going to look now at a show a
more simple example
um
of the same
the same kind of thinking
where is it
um
actually i don't think i have oh here it
is
okay
and we will clear the make it so it's
not visible
this is
a very weird position
white's up at night
but
the position is very blocked and so it's
going to take some really unusual
maneuvers to win this game
so does anyone have an idea how white's
going to win
a4 okay so
uh
knight to a4 so the first step is well
yep lincoln also found found the idea so
the first step that we the only thing
white can do is bring the knight over to
a4 because clearly
taking here
it's not going to win because the black
king easily stops the c pawn and white
has no way to to do anything with the
king for instance so the only thing
white could do however
uh we we do know that in some cases we
can sacrifice this knight for a pawn and
win
the only thing to do though we don't
even if we don't see this all the way to
the end
is to bring the knight around to b2
because clearly the only place it can go
to c1 and then only from there to e2 and
from there only to g1 unless we're going
to go back obviously which doesn't do
anything then to h3 and then to f2 and
then to d1 and then to b2 and then to
a4 okay
so we're going to do all that and the
black king is going to come up to c6 and
we're going to have the position with
the knight on a4 and the black king on
c6
is the knight kept out from black's
position then
you can waste a tempo very good move the
king to b2
and the king will have to move away from
c6 and then the knight can jump in to b6
right
i'm going to play through this on the
board but first let's try to visualize
it now once the knight gets to b6
is it over the white knight has broken
into black's camp
but can it actually achieve anything
there
bring the knight over to the h6 pawn
so once we get this knight into b6
black has three vulnerable points
but the problem is that these two ones
on on c5 and e5 can be easily guarded by
the black king
and black can prevent white from
attacking h6 because it can only get
attack h6 really from f5 i mean it's not
going to get to f7 or g8
but how is the knight going to get to f5
the knight can get to d5 but the black
king will sit on e6 there
okay let me there's too many arrows here
let's i'll clear out all these arrows
there is some key combination it clears
them all out at once but
yeah okay so at this point we figured
out we can get the knight to b6 the
black king is hovering somewhere around
d6
we're not going to win c5 because if
knight a4 black's always going to have
king d6 or king c6
um we can bring the knight from b6 to d5
but the black king sits on
e6 or f7
and then we can't get the knight to e7
he just moves back and forth
we can go knight c7 but then the king
comes back
comes back to e7 and we go knight a6 the
king goes to d6
okay so we're sitting here in a
tournament game let's imagine in some
other world we actually got positions
like this in a tournament game
i don't think it would happen
but still
okay
we don't we know there's no other plan
to use other than bringing the knight to
a4 we can bring the knight to a4 and
then sit there and figure it out then so
we start off with
bringing the knight around okay
okay let's let's suppose black did this
by the way
and
a little bit clever but okay now white
king goes there giving black the move
and because of zug swung black has to
move his king to d6
now there's nothing to do but bring the
knight up
and here black needs to be smart
to have the best defense if he goes here
then the knight easily invades
like
this and gets to g8 and takes the pawn
but instead of doing instead of going to
c6 he's going to go to e6
realizing what white's trying to do
well now he's still in range of guarding
c5 he's already guarding e5
but he's not letting the knight get to
any of these key squares from which it
can reach f5 so knight d5 for instance
he goes only one move here to defend
have to keep this the knight out of this
square in that square
so what is black play
king f7 right and now it's just going to
sit there and move back and forth
and just laugh at the opponent
but white has a way to make progress
here
and can anyone figure it out this is
where it starts to get tricky and we
need to think in a very scam in a
schematic way this is not calculation
this is schematic thinking which is
part of end game play
especially in blocked positions or slow
positions we saw it a lot in the
smithslav botvinnik game or bought the
next muslim game
so lincoln says knight c7 but what's the
idea
we can make lots of moves we can go
knight c7 we can go king a2 king b1 king
a1 but we need to find an idea okay you
want to target to c5 pawn okay so king
c7
threatening knight a6 but black can
defend against that he plays king e7
only move
and if knight a6 then king d6
and here the position's drawn
because the knight will not get out
again the knight is now trapped
knight b8 king c7 knight a6 king b6
and of course the night sacrifice never
works because the position is still too
blocked
so let's go back to this position
attacking c5 didn't work because black
is still close enough with the king to
defend it
any other ideas
yeah but okay i mean if it goes to d7
the black king will get to d6 but i'm
not sure you can even get to d7 either
let's think about this in a different
way
in order to win the game
we have to attack oops we have to attack
the h pawn
because attacking these pawns the black
king can guard them but if we could get
our knight to f5
the h pawn would be lost because
if even if the king is on h7 black would
fall into zug's wong because
there's no moves with a knight on f5 and
the black king on h7 you'll lose the h
pawn and once the h pawn is lost the
game will be over
so knight f5 was decisi oops knight of
five is decisive
but black is covering like we saw he's
preventing the knight from getting to e7
clearly can't get to g7
i mean if knight here trying to get to
e8 and then g7 black just goes here
as we saw
how else could white get to f5
i mean we can burn as many tempos as we
want but black just goes here and he's
just moving back and forth
yeah
burn as many tempe as we want
but
black can just wait
d6 but we're not going to get to d6 a
good idea but
black's also going to prevent this for
instance here
here
he's going to stay guarding d6 he'll
play this move
or even king d7 is acceptable as well
how from what squares can white get to
f5
just
legally right e7 d6 g7
e3
okay probably not going to come from e3
though right
where else
g3
okay now we're getting some ideas
because if the knight got to g3 but the
problem is black could take it because
that king and pawn ending is still drawn
because it's still blocked what else
h4
so now we get some ideas maybe if we
could get our knight to h4
anyone see away now i think
i think shawn
i think sean might have seen it
because he says ah yes
so how can the knight get to h4
anyone no
you can't come all the way back uh-huh
you can come all the way back what's
throughout
c7 c7 and then
b5 and then
a3 because black can't take on a3 that
king and pawn ending is winning
right we'll see that in a second we if
we if it's not clear yet so tom here
says
go back whence it came
yes
or i don't know how that's pronounced b6
a4 b2 that would be exactly where from
whence it came that wouldn't work
because at that point we're not making
any problems we're not going exactly
back from whence it came we're going on
a little
slightly different uh circuit we were
going eight two
i mean a2 to c1 to e2 to g1 to h3 and we
were the knight was trapped in this
little
little place and then it came out by a
via a4
we're not going to go back into that
into that
prison
we're going to take a different route
like like you just said knight c7
knight b5 knight a3
and black won't be able to take because
when white takes here now the king will
get further ahead and even if black king
we're on a5 well we'll see that in a
second okay so
knight c7 oh it's black's move though in
this position let's just so
king e6 knight d5 king f7 knight c7
king e7 knight b5 let's suppose the
black king goes over here
well
let's now can black take it
king takes right
and after king c6 king a4
and b4
and black takes and king takes
and then for instance here and this king
and pawn ending we've opened up enough
space the king comes through we take all
these pawns and
so that's it it wouldn't even matter
let's say if black could have got the
king to a5 with white's move here white
would still have b4 cb king b3
reaching the same kind of thing
so knight a3 is okay black doesn't take
the knight black continues
marking time with the king king e6 what
now
c2
e1 and g2 and we're ready to go to h4
right
okay knight c2
now black says okay i'll probably need
my king over on the king side not that
it makes a difference
okay
now can we go knight
h4 that that would be a little hasty
right yes
[Music]
now we're now the next step is to move
our king over
okay we have all the time in the world
move the king
over we're playing without an opponent
now let me get the temp tempe right here
let's say so that black makes the best
defensive chance he can
um
so he goes king f6 king h3 and now
whether king g7 or king h7 once the
knight gets to f5 if black doesn't take
the knight
with the king on h7 as we saw black is
as we'll see black is lost so if he does
this for instance and white comes here
and black doesn't take it knight f5
and black is in suge song and white
takes the pawn once that pawn is
captured the knight comes back around
and takes this pawn and this pawn is
keeping the black king busy so that's
over even if it were black white's moved
here white would just make a tempo move
with the king
okay so let's go back and let's say
let's say black makes his best defensive
try king of s7
knight h4
now we see that the knight is coming in
and the h pawn is lost so black tries
taking the knight
king takes king f6 the final point what
is y2 here
g5 typical breakthrough could have done
the same thing on the queen side if
black could have got
the king on a5 in the variation with ba
it would have been the same thing g5 hg
king g4
and black has to give way because he has
no moves duke song king takes g5
and then it's over
white can just go take these pawns and
the game is over
so really incredible position and i'm
and i and this is a great one to show
because i really don't think computers
can solve this i'm not sure because i'm
not really
i i'm not an expert in computer chess
and i try to avoid it whenever possible
but
i think it's beyond the horizon of
computers so they they can make all
these individual moves but they're not
going to find the idea and
the calculation required is beyond the
horizon because i don't know where it's
about
let's see i don't know how many moves
let me try to
open this up
we're at 30 moves at this point
yeah so i think it's beyond the horizon
of the computer and they're not capable
of finding a plan like that
so if you set up this position to play
against on a computer and you have black
even against the best computers now i'm
not sure about this but you can run an
experiment
and
let me know
if if the computer was able to beat you
obviously you have to try to make the
best defensive moves too
so that's i'm not sure where this
position came from uh someone someone
invented it i'm not i don't even
remember where i found it
uh i don't know who the composer is so
if anyone figures that out somehow that
would also be interesting
anyway i hope you enjoyed this this has
been grand master brian smith
with the st louis chess club showing you
insane in the end game
[Music]
you